a secret if you watch one of the
trailers keep an eye on this one
Bugman he actually gets a little bit
bigger
he's just chunky he's like 30% bigger
than cuphead and we recorded the trailer
footage we realized we had created thick
mud man hi I'm Jared moldenhauer the
lead game design for studio m.d. HR and
I'm here to take you on a journey
through King dice dice Palace it's all
the little nuances it's little brief
details it's how we finally got to the
end package it's a mix of insight it's
got game pro pro tips it has it all so I
hope you enjoy so this is it this is our
omage to gun star heroes and the dice
palace this is a earlier stage where
it's a very plain like it's just kind of
a straight-line path whereas the gun
star heroes was a vertical now I don't
remember perfectly but I remember it
swings back
that's probably one more swing than it
needed to be this was the beginning of
being like it's on a gambling table it's
at the casino so what we got here is
kind of like really early stages a
little bit more experimental with how
could you view the player like change a
camera which was kind of silly like
switch it to more of a top-down but the
the look of like king dice so far down
like just so minut being like almost
unnoticeable and completely unnoticeable
we just kind of kept pursuing a little
bit more so this is some production are
from tipsy troop all of this side is
potential death animations so what we
always do is end up trying to feel out
what's the most unique or what stays
with their personalities more and
knowing that we want them to stay on the
screen during the fight during their
death animations something
like shattering is just a no and a no
there's something that we just realized
is a error this balancing sha
disappearing on their hitbox is not
intended every other shot in the game
passes through and allows you to hit the
final guy but thanks to GameSpot
professionals you can look forward to
this in an update patch 1.2 yeah this is
just a overall a good example of like
how much we try to explore facial
expressions like this is more of like
kind of a sad and then you get your med
over here this is I don't even know what
you want to call it the more angles you
approach in the design of the character
sometimes you get surprised and it
switches the entirety of how they feel
Hoppus pocus is kind of a creepy little
magician this death animation his tie is
kind of choking him now this isn't the
inspiration but I like to pretend it is
there was this one time my brother in
elementary school one of our friends had
just got his nice new scarf on and was
going home and he decided like let's
yank on each side it wasn't me it wasn't
me I'm free of this one and it ended up
like tightening the knot so much that it
couldn't be undone so this sort of
represents the time where my brother
nearly murdered a child but because he's
a good kind man he was the one who also
ran to get a pair of scissors to cut
that scarf off that's probably not
usable and he won't like it
so what we got here is mr. wheezy the
ideas that we kind of wanted to do was
make sure we got gambling themed but
then also what else
beam's well with casinos the booze and
the cigarettes and they're like smoky
atmosphere there's the tipsy trio and as
well we have our giant cigar character
this was death concepts like what is the
chaos beam gonna be but this whole
concept this idea that like maybe he
could just kind of burn and be reduced
to ashes actually ended up how he
travels from the side of the screen once
a concept is complete we have the
characters of Pippin da dun like we go
through a quick thumbnails we know what
the tax sort of gonna be but we want to
let the artists explore a little bit
more as you're creating or trying to
find something you also got to get like
the half-baked ideas out there or
anything the the least explored and
actually in the game was belly mouth
there was just something about it the
head that thirty's nightmarish catch you
off-guard
like it's something just a little bit
outside of your expectation this has
kind of a funny death animation yes that
that keyframe is just lovely I think a
lot of people miss these kind of little
small details and nuances because you've
just achieved it you've just finally
defeated the boss and your brain kind of
shuts off it's kind of nice to sometimes
like go back and see these odd nuances
within the game here's one of the pages
one of the many pages of pure Oleta the
original sketches kinda head up more
Square top on the holder and we knew we
wanted a boss that is a large rectangle
essentially a secret if you watch one of
the trailers this plat
Bugman when he lands on it he actually
gets a little bit bigger we refer to it
as like thick mug man he's just chunky
he's like 30% bigger than Cup head had
to do with just it's within unity the
way we had reacting to some of the
boundary systems is you if we you just
stretched them manually than anything
that was interacting with it would also
follow the exact same stretch so at some
point probably me screwed this up and we
recorded the trailer footage but thank
God we did because within that trailer
footage and early footage of looking at
it we realized we had created thick
mcgrann so what we have here is an Amash
within via maj so the gunstar heroes
dice palace this part in GunStar heroes
for some reason stuck with both of us we
were like how can we pull that into our
game and we wanted to do an homage but
never be overtly one thing we didn't
want somebody playing cop head and taken
out of the universe going this is from
that game so everything that we kind of
tried to achieve is very subtle like you
almost have to look for it or want to
look for it we sort of want to cut head
to be a love letter to all retro-gaming
but some stages like the junkyard or
this arcade the claw picker I don't even
know what you call those machines the
claw picked games what you got here is
monkey and a wolf and over in the corner
is a lizard so this is kind of our
homage to rampage it's basically george
lizzie and ralph every boss in the game
there's gonna be somewhere between like
two to six things that's kind of a nod
to something that we grew up with and we
we loved so we thought why not pay it an
homage in a way without being a direct
ripoff
here it is our final surprise our final
mean you got to the finish line who
knows what's gonna happen next you're
celebrating you put the controller down
and before you know you look back up and
the screen is full of cards there's
nowhere left to go by the time you get
your bounds you've probably lost that
round you probably cursed us out
maybe I'm partially sorry about that
it's so amazing in the end to like
finally see your game played like
launching it was amazing but there's
something about being like so burnt out
your brains just kind of like I need to
reset I need a month or six it's the
like the streaming and the speedrunners
and the stuff that really kind of
brought back that joy to like it's
almost on par with the feeling of
launching the game it's just a beautiful
thing to be a part of this entire
community we're really grateful and I
don't think we could change a single
thing about the way we approached it the
way it was done and we're just happy you
guys liked it thanks